[Music]
sam is with us in albany new york hey
sam how are you
hey what's going on dave i'm doing well
how are you doing better than i deserve
how can i help you
all right uh so double question well a
question
about the current housing market and
how much would be appropriate to spend
on a house based on my income
i currently am making around 14 to 1600
net
every week and
i am planning on getting engaged shortly
and so i would like to purchase the
house so i don't know if this is an
appropriate time to do that or if i
should wait
six months seven months and then do it
do you have any debt no definitely
good you got your emergency fund in
place of three to six months of expenses
yes okay well what we tell folks is to
never buy a home that is more than a
fourth
of your take-home pay on a 15-year
fixed and so that puts you at about a
1500 house payment
on a 15-year fixed that's about what you
can afford now your down payment of
course is
how much you save between now and then
add to that equation
you're getting married i'm okay if you
wait till a year after you're married
um actually there's a lot of wisdom in
that it takes about a year of being
married to know how close to your
mother-in-law to buy
okay you kind of got to get to know your
wife because the problem with buying a
house before you're married is
you will discover after you got married
that you bought the wrong house because
she will tell you
yes sir so that can happen i mean it's
happened before
all the guys all the old guys are
laughing right now so uh
yeah but the uh uh you know so i mean
it's
it's up to you you could you can buy but
i would have her
uh not make the decision but be very
involved in the selection so you don't
have to rebuy later
and i'm not going to do any of this out
of a panic because i'm worried about
this real estate market this real estate
market's crazy
but here's the thing yeah real estate is
not a short play it's a long play
here's what i mean okay how old are you
uh 24. good for you okay when i was
the house that i bought when i was 24
uh was 52 000 today it would sell for
a half a million
[Laughter]
okay i'm 60. i'm 60. so
what's the point of that the point of
that is and by the way the real estate
market was quite hot when i bought that
house
it was crazy people were just going nuts
interest rates were coming down after
having been really high
and uh everybody was just jumping on
anything that moved it was kind of a
little bit like now
right now it's hotter but uh point being
that all of this stuff
measures out and mellows out given a
little given a couple of decades here or
there
and so you're probably not going to be
in the house you buy that long anyway
five or 10 years
on average and uh and you're gonna you
know so if you wait a year to buy it and
it goes up some
it's gonna go up more between now and
the time you're old like me
so you got plenty of time dude um so
there's nothing
don't ever get house fever like oh god
if we don't buy a house we're gonna be
priced out of the market
i mean you know yeah if you don't buy a
house for 60 years you'll be priced out
of the market but if you don't buy a
house for two years you're not gonna be
priced out of the market
that doesn't happen because the markets
come and go they soften they get better
they get stronger back and forth and
over the scope of your life you're gonna
see a lot of interesting stuff with real
estate but it's not a short
term play it's a very difficult to make
money on real estate in the short term
uh but you can almost always make money
on real estate in the long play
it's a it's man you do a decade play
with real estate you can really set
yourself up for some serious money
very nice very nice great job man
congratulations on the upcoming
engagement hang on i'm gonna send you a
copy the total money makeover for you to
read through with your new bride nine
million people have
and so you should too hang on
uh open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's what we do here
we talk about getting you out of debt in
the shortest possible time
and it's not just about getting out of
debt it's about getting out of debt so
that you can be outrageously generous
it's about getting out of debt so that
you change your family tree
it's about getting control because if
you can control your spending you're
controlling almost every aspect of your
life
because it all flows through your
spending just about money's not
important at all
what it does oh when it puts food on the
table and
shoes on your kids it's really important
so what it does is important money
itself it really doesn't matter
so it's all about control it's all about
growing up and it's all about
long-term thinking and maturity and
we'll help you do that it's what we've
done for 30 years